Man fragt sich ja, was zur Hölle passiert noch Detective Florenton Folge 1.
Zuhause kommt da jemand vorbei, also wirklich die zwielichtigste Gestalt aller Zeiten, klopft an, Gefahr ist im Verzug und als B-Story. Schöner Tag, Brezelstand, Stefan Tietze Brezel in der Hand und BATZ! Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcast-UFO. Es ist halt diese typische Schulterzug-Folge, dieses jetzt ist auch alles egal, wir wissen nicht genau, was passiert. Ist es noch ein Podcast, machen wir das, hört das eh noch jemand? Was ist hier los? Bin ich Florentin? Bist du Stefan? Die Abrufzeiten sind schon seit Wochen einfach nur noch Fragezeichen, xx3, 404 Error x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x, x,ungen erlege, weil ich glaube, ich bin schwer verwundet. Ich glaube, ich bin schwer verletzt. Geht es seelisch oder was? Du bist ja die ganze Zeit schon so sassy und arrogant und gemein, aber gut, dann weiss es dann nichts einfach daran, dass deine Gehirnblutung jetzt langsam durchsickert. Kann sein, weil ich habe natürlich... Ganz kurz, wollen wir kurz, bevor deine Gehirnblutung noch präsentiert, sagen, wie das Intro war. Richtig, das war von Simon, vielen, vielen Dank für dieses fantastische... Simon zwei oder Simon fünf? Nee, es ist der Original Simon, also er benennt sich selber als Simon. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Arroganz von seiner Seite aus ist oder ob das auch mit den Behörden so abgesprochen ist, aber er ist einfach Simon. Vielen, vielen Dank für dieses ... Gut, sorry, zurück zur Gehirnblutung. Zurück zu meinem Notfall, genau. Zurück zu meinem Notfall, Herr Doktor Tietze. Nee, ganz kurz, wenn Sie mir kurz noch mal in die Wasserflasche reichen könnten. Oh, nicht der. Alles. Ja, bitteschön.itteschön dankeschön boah ich gestern ich habe auch so tauben arm weil gestern habe ich tennis gespielt ja und dann sind wir seitdem aber gut ich rede schon wieder nur von mir sie wollten mir um den unfall sprechen vielleicht müssen sie sich ein bisschen mehr aufhören vom sport ja sie wollten von dem unfall erzählen genau also ich war auf der autobahn und plötzlich Ich bin ja großer Mate-Trinker und ich mag die Mate sehr gern kalt, so bin ich ehrlich, und deswegen lege ich sie gerne ins Gefrierfach und heute ist das passiert, was unweigerlich passieren muss. So, du hast sie vergessen, die ist geplatzt, in dein Gesicht geplatzt. Genau, wenn man den Gierhals mal wieder nicht zukriegt und sagt, da geht noch ein bisschen kälter, es geht noch ein bisschen kälter. Ich bin da auf Kelvins Spuren, der sagt, da geht noch weniger. Glaubst du, Kelvin hat die Temperatur entdeckt, weil er die Mate kalt machen wollte? Ich glaube auch, der hat gehört, 0 Grad Celsius, hold my mate. Und er geht noch weniger als 0 Grad und hat immer kälter, kälter, kälter, bis es nicht mehr geht. Und Fahrenheit hat die ganze Zeit kam um die Ecke mit seinen anderen Einheiten und sowas. Stockbesoffener Fahrenheit.
Nach noch 160 ist so ein bisschen warm, okay.
Ich bin drei Ellen von dir entfernt mit ganz anderen Einheiten und alle immer, wer ist der und ich verstehe nicht. Ich habe drei Zentner Kartoffelsalat dabei. Kein Mensch versteht dich, Fahrenheit.
Ich gebe dir fünf Dutzend Goldstücke.
Drei Unzen für ein Schaf, Das ist Fahrenheit. Flamboyant Fahrenheit. Mit so einem grossen Mantel stell ich mir vor, so einem Gehstock. Ja, Geburtstag am 3.5. Ja, was, was? Im KW 19 werde ich wiederkommen. Genau, Fahrenheit ist auch so ein KW-Typ. Es wäre eigentlich ganz gut, wenn Gandalf gesagt hätte, er sagt dann irgendwann, wenn die Sonne gen Osten aufgeht, blickt Richtung Westen, dann er sagt, ich komme in KW 13 wieder. Und Eomer so, KW, du meinst nächste Woche. Und dreht sich so um, Gandalf, und er ist weg schon. Und er so, wann ist KW 19? Warte, es war doch gerade Silvester. KW1, ah, ist herrlich,
KW18. Aber zurück zu deinem
Notfall. Genau, zurück zu meinem
tödlichen Notfall.
Und natürlich kriege ich den
Hals nicht voll, ich bin Gierhals
und dann lag diese
zerborstene Flasche in meinem Gefrierfach,
aber ich habe mir gedacht, wir sind alle mal
zerborsten, jeder hat mal so einen Tag, wo man
sich zerborsten fühlt und
ich will die gute Martha
aber nicht verlieren, ich will sie nicht verlieren.
Der Inhalt ist ein sehr. Auch wenn die Schale zerborsten ist, der Inhalt ist noch süss. Also das ist als Eis konsumiert. Also habe ich diese mit Rissen durchzogene Flasche genommen und wollte sie trotzdem als Flasche nutzen. Oh mein Gott, bist du bescheuert. Und die Öffnung war komplett zersplittert. Ich habe versucht, dann noch so einzelne Scherben rauszunehmen. Da dachte ich mir, das geht schon, das geht schon und habe das dann getrunken und danach ein paar Schlücken habe ich mich echt ganz ungut gefühlt. Also ich musste wirklich mal... Aber mir kippt es jetzt so langsam von ...
Haha, du übertreibst auch ein bisschen jetzt für den Podcast die Story, aber ganz ehrlich, du sitzt vor mir, du sitzt auch ein bisschen blass aus. Bei mir kippt es jetzt so langsam von Haha, zerborsten, Gierhals, hin zu ... Wo wir drüber reden? Nee, mir geht es wirklich, also ich habe wirklich hier einen medizinischenstand gerade. Und ich habe da so ein bisschen getrunken und dachte mir, was soll da passieren? Mein Gott, ein bisschen Glas im Magenglas, in der Speiseröhre. Wird doch zersetzt von der Magensäure. Ich denke mir, die Magensäure klärt. Die kriegt alles hin so. Magensäure regelt. Ja, die Magensäure ist so ein bisschen wie so eine Mutter, die kümmert sich schon drum. Du vergisst ewig, ich habe kein Praktikum, mich gekümmert. Ja, komm, da mache ich das. Magensäure klärt alles auf. Und nach ein paar Schlücken, und dann kennst du das, wenn du dich schlecht fühlst und kurz innehalten musst. Kennst du das, wenn du Scherben trinkst? Aber es gibt ja so schlechte Gefühle, man fühlt sich irgendwie nicht gut, aber man kann trotzdem noch weitermachen mit dem, was man macht. Man fühlt trotzdem noch sein Leben weiter, man hat so dieses Gefühl, mir geht es gerade nicht gut. Aber dann gibt es manchmal so ein Gefühl, wo du sagst, nee, jetzt muss ich kurz mal innehalten und mich mal kurz diesem Gefühl widmen und kurz mal sitzen bleiben und sagen. Was war denn das für ein Gefühl? Wo kam das Gefühl her? Das Gefühl war vielleicht ausgelöst durch innere Blutungen, man weiss das ja oft nicht so. Traumata oder so verschiedene Psychologen und Psychoanalytiker haben da unterschiedliche Meinungen. Ist es Glas im Bauch oder ist es ein Kindheitstraumata? Man weiss es halt doch nicht. Aber wo kam denn das Gefühl her, das ungute Gefühl? Naja, ich habe dann irgendwann gemerkt, okay, ich habe da irgendwas im Mund und es war dann halt einfach eine Scherbe. Und dann hatte ich auch auf der Lippe noch so eine Scherbe und dann dachte ich mir, nee, jetzt lass uns das mal abbrechen. Habe aber durchaus schon einige Schlücke Mate konsumiert. Es kann gut sein, dass das Glas in mir haust, eingezogen ist und da so schnell nicht mehr aus kann. Ich weiß es nicht. Die Magensäure kann der Glas nicht zersetzen wahrscheinlich. Das würde ich sagen, selbst für Magensäure sind da die Hände gebunden. Dafür sind wir nicht zuständig. Damit habe ich nichts zu tun. Das geht weiter an den Dünndarm, soll der sich um den den Scheiss kümmern. Aber ich weiß... Das weiß ich jetzt nicht wie Glas. Hast du mal gegoogelt oder ist es dir dann doch noch so egal? Nee, ich habe dann auch angefangen zu zittern und konnte kaum noch tippen. Ich konnte gerade noch den Aufnahmetermin hergekommen. Ich weiß es nicht. Und warum trinkst du immer noch aus der Mateflasche? Ich bin ja auf dem Parkplatz aufgewacht und war da. Ich konnte gerade noch den Aufnahmetermin bestätigen und konnte dann noch hierher humpeln. Und ich glaube, das war es. Also ich glaube, meine letzten Stunden haben angebrochen. Aber zum Glück werden meine letzten Worte aufgezeichnet. Ist ja oft das Problem. Das ist cool, das ist richtig cool, wie Nachwelt. Ja, dass die letzten Worte nicht aufgezeichnet wird, länger der natürlich Einstein, der im toten Bett lag und dann irgendwie die letzten Worte gesagt hat und die einzige Krankenschwester, die bei ihm war, hat kein Deutsch gesprochen.
Ja, blöd, dann ist ja jetzt einfach die Weltformel.
Ich habe noch eine Formel gelöst.
E ist fünf.
Komme?
Was?
Komme.
Das Letzte, was du hörst, ist Komme.
Aber ich fände, das wäre ein angemessener Tod, ein angemessens der Tod. Ja, du willst ja als Künstler, ich sehe mich als Künstler, du auch. Ich sehe dich auch als Künstler. Genau, ihr alle seht mich als Künstler, ich sehe mich ja als Künstler und da möchte ich natürlich auf der Bühne sterben. Das ist natürlich das grosse Ziel, bei einer riesigen von der Pyrotechnik erfasst werden und auf der Bühne bei lebendigem Leib verbrennen, während man ein unverkennbares Gitarrensolo von sich gibt.
Als Künstler willst du sterben, entweder a auf der Bühne, b Flugzeugabsturz, c Terroranschlag, d plötzlicher Unfall, genau Hotelzimmer, d Überdosis, e Müllpresse, du willst während dem Videodreh auf dem Schrottplatz in die Müllpresse fallen, F, Stuntunfall, G, irgendwas anderes, was irgendwie grob mit dem Werk zu tun hat, H, Überdosis, wo erschossen werden, finde ich auch immer cool. Immer cool? Ja. Das hatte ich neulich, da war ich abends in einer dunklen Gasse unterwegs und habe hinter mir Gestalten im Schatten rumhuschen sehen, wo ich dachte, vielleicht werde ich jetzt erschossen, aber auch cool. Ja. Auch ein cooler Tod, wenn man mal eine Leiche findet und dann habe ich eine Schusswunde und dann denkt man, weil dann spinnt sich halt ja automatisch alles grösser als es ist. Ja. Ich meine, ich wollte einfach auch nur abends mal zum Kiosk, um mir Reese's Pieces zu kaufen. Und dann habe ich den doch einen Schluss bekommen. Ich glaube, irgendwie, dann wird mein Werk grösser gemacht, als es dann auch eigentlich war. Ich würde Geschichten erzählen. Ich würde sagen, du hast dich vor jemandem geworfen, der eigentlich hätte erschossen werden sollen. Du hast dich vor Guido Kanz geworfen, der in einem Drive-By-Shooting eigentlich von der ProSieben-Crew hätte ausgeschaltet werden sollen. Aber du hast dich vor ihm geworfen mit der letzten Kraft und klammerst du mit deinen kalten Toten. Um die deutsche Comedy zu retten, dann doch. Du wolltest deine Reasons Pieces nicht abgeben, die du in deiner kalten Handklammern festhältst. Es sind wie diese Perlen von Batman, die dann durch die Gegend, they were everywhere, they were everywhere, die Reasons Pieces, die der Räuber aber nicht mitgenommen hat. Hat der Räuber die Perlen geklaut von der Mutter von Swain? Ging es dem überhaupt um die Perlen? Ja, schon um die Perlen. Richtig? Ging es um die Perlen? Wenn du die Perlen alle so verstreust, dann sind die schwer aufzusammeln. Ich frage mich, also ob dann nicht auch die ganzen Folgen nochmal sich angehört würden und Stefan hat da vor drei Folgen von diesem ominösen Menschen gesprochen, der am Fenster stand, vielleicht hat der was mit seinem Tod zu tun. Stimmt, die Jugendlichen, die das Fahrrad klauen wollen. Genau, ob dann nicht vielleicht jetzt nach und nach halt die Folgen dann wie so mit roten Bindfäden an die Wände gelegt werden, um dann meinen Mord aufzuklären. Im Endeffekt war es einfach nur ein komischer Unfall und jemand ist auf den Trigger gekommen und ich wollte dieses Pieces kaufen. Das ist wahrscheinlich ja dann die Realität, aber ich weiß nicht, so ein Mord macht es halt irgendwie cooler. Auf jeden Fall, ich glaube auch, dass bei der Polizei gerade so neue Abteilungen gegründet werden, die immer, wenn jemand ermordet wird, sich deren Podcast anhören müssen, ob da Hinweise drin sind. Weil mittlerweile hat gut 80 Prozent der Bevölkerung ein Podcast. Es ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wenn jemand ermordet wurde, der einen Podcast hat, und dann muss man reinhören, muss irgendeinen Polizeibeamter in den Podcast feiern, die 460 Folgen durchhören. Ja, das ist die Podcast-Polizei, die despektierlich gerade noch kurz Popo genannt werden. Entschuldigen, können wir vielleicht einen anderen Namen? Podcast-Polizei? Popo? Ja, aber Popo ist, das klingt wirklich zu klein. Hä, wieso? Die Autobotscheid ist auch... Wir müssen den ganzen Tag grottenschlechte Podcasts mit schlechter Audioqualität hören, mit fünf Abonnenten, die irgendwie sagen, haha, wir rufen jetzt irgendwo Klingelstreicher an oder so, da geht keiner ran. Die Autobahnpolizei das auch Aupo. Und, wir nennen die halt alle so. Das ist halt die normalen Abkürzungs- Ja. Popo bitte drei. Ja? Ja. Nee, aber genau. Ich finde, das ist ein gutes Framework für dein Leben. Also wenn dein Ende ist, eine Mischung aus bodenloser Dummheit und Mate, fasst das finde ich ganz gut zusammen. Das darf ich gar nicht erzählen. Ich halte mich mittlerweile wirklich für fast wirklich abgrundtief dumm. Also vor allem so manchmal überrasche ich mich selber. Letztens lage ich im Bett und merke, ich habe meine Maske an. Also halt diese Corona-Maske. Und ich denke, und dann denke ich mir, was ist hier passiert? Moment, wie oft bin ich falsch abgebogen und an dem Punkt sein? Anscheinend habe ich, weil ich habe die immer vor meiner Tür liegen, wenn ich rausgehe, nehme ich die mit. Und irgendwie scheint mein Gehirn falsch gescheitert zu sein und hat verwechselt, ich gehe ins Bett mit, ich gehe raus und ich habe mir völlig selbstverständlich die Maske angezogen. Aber Moment, du bist dann quasi, also du warst nochmal im Bad, Zähneputzen oder sowas, die Scherben aus deinem Mund. Die fegen, Scherben aus meinem Hals rausnehmen müssen, wie jeden Abend. Wie jeden Abend, klar, weil das ja auch, warum sieht es vorhin, wie es das erste Mal passiert ist, wird gerade so dargestellt. Du hast die Scherben raus, das Blut aus dem Waschbecken gefegt, wie jeden Abend, und dann gehst du raus, kommst an deiner Tür vielleicht vorbei, Richtung Schlafzimmer, richtig?
Ja, ja.
Kommst an deiner Tür vorbei, nimmst die Maske.
Schlafzimmer ist ein bisschen eher hoch, aber ja.
Aber hast du eine Schlafmaske für deine Augen?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Aber ich hatte die Maske an, das ist so komplett bescheuert.
Also ich kann, vor allem bis dahin habe ich es nicht gemerkt und dann irgendwann, das hätte gut sein können, dass ich eingeschlafen wäre und es nicht gemerkt hätte und es einfach so hingenommen habe, einfach so hingenommen hätte.
Aber ich bin auch vorsichtig, seitdem ich mal wieder, weil ich ja eigentlich nicht mache, aber dann doch übergebracht habe, Kommentare gelesen im Rocket Beans Forum, wo ich mich, wo ich tief getroffen war, über einen negativen Kommentar nicht gefunden habe.
Stefan hatte die ganze Zeit ein Wattestäbchen im Ohr stecken, während der gesamten Sendung. Wie kann das sein? Ah, scheiße, ja, sorry. Was hat da in mir gefallen? Hat die Maske die ganze Zeit aufgehabt, man hat ihn nicht verstanden. Und es war der Kommentar, Stefan Thiese kommt im Podcast auf Ufo eher unintelligent rüber. Ja. So, da habe ich mich wirklich getroffen.
Aber es war auch, ich fände es aber lustig, weil es im Channel Unpopular Opinions war.
Das heißt, es war so ein vergiftetes Kompliment auf eine Art auch.
Es war entweder ein vergiftetes Kompliment oder eine süße, ein süsses Lüge, was?
Ein süsses Gift.
Ja, ich komme eher, wie man merkt, eher unintelligent rüber. Aber weil es ist halt wirklich einfach, man kann es in beide Richtungen interpretieren. Ja, das stimmt. Diejenige Person, die mich da nicht mag oder eher für unintelligent hält, ist auch erst mal nett formuliert, eher unintelligent. Also im Internet ist ja eher der Sprech kommt sau dumm rüber. Ich finde dann eher intelligent fast verletzender, weil das andere ist Hate, das ist eher eine konstruktive, eine konstruktive Kommentar.
Das klingt eher wie eine objektive Einschätzung, als Experten, als wirklich Hass.
Ja, das ist eine differenzierte Skala von intelligent, eher intelligent, weiß ich nicht, eher unintelligent. Es ist wie so eine Bachelorarbeit auf eine Art, so eine Bachelorumfrage, hat dann rechts angekreuzt, eher unintelligent, aber halt im im Channel unpopular opinions, heisst denkt, dass es eher eine unpopular opinion ist, was ja eigentlich eine gute Sache ist. Ja, das ist schwierig einzuschätzen, wenn du sagst unpopular opinion, Florentin ist fett, dann denkst du, niemand würde dir zustimmen, also du relativierst selbst deine Aussage eigentlich. So und ein Like, dann habe ich mich gefragt, was bedeutet ein Like unter diesem Kommentar? Jetzt sind es komziert. Weil ist der Like richtig, du hast diesen Thread getroffen, das ist eine unpopular Opinion, oder ist der Like, ja, das sehe ich auch so, obwohl es unpopular ist? Also das hat auf jeden Fall, ich wusste nicht, auch mein ganzer Körper, kennst du das ja, wenn man einen negativen Kommentar über sich sieht, manchmal hat man dieses tiefe, komische Gefühl. Genau, dieses kratzende Gefühl im Mund, so diese schärfe, schärfe im Mund, ja. Ja, genau, man weiß nicht, woher es kommt, es könnte auch an der Made liegen, aber halt dieses komische Gefühl im Magen. Ja. Und das hatte ich da auch, aber dann auch wieder, es war so wie so ein Wackelkontakt von einem Lichtschalter, weil man Körper diese Informationen nicht verarbeiten konnte.
Diese vierschichtige Beleidigung. Eher unintelligent, aber im Channel Unpopular Opinions. Hat es Likes? Was bedeuten die Likes? Ist es etwas Gutes? Ist es Unpopular? Bin ich Popular? Ich weiß es nicht. Das ist eh strange. Also diese Unpopular Opinions sind eh ein Phänomen. Ich war ja lange auf Nine-Gag unterwegs auch und da gibt es ja auch dann diesen Unpopular Opinion, diesen Vogel, der da so durch die Gegend läuft. Und da gibt es dann auch Unpopular Opinion irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwas. Und dann denkt man sich aber auch, ja gut, das wurde halt auf die Hauptseite gewartet, ne, dieser Post. So Unpopular kann die Opinion nicht sein. Was heisst das jetzt? Also wie kann man etwas Unpopuläres überhaupt konsumieren durch einen Algorithmus? Wie viele Upvotes braucht ein Post in Unpopular Opinions, um einfach gelöscht zu werden in dem Thread? Genau. Es müsste eigentlich andersrum laufen, da müssen die, die ganz wenig haben, oben sein. Ja, das ist ein Paradox. Je mehr Leute sie liken, desto weiter streichen sie ab. Popular Posts im Thread, Unpopular Opinions, entschuldigt die ganzen englischen Wörter. Wirklich kompliziert. Es gehört eigentlich dann irgendwann gelöscht. Also nullt sich er selber. Ja, ja, ja. Gut, haben wir das geklärt. Zurück zur Notung. Wie geht es dir denn jetzt gerade? Ja. Weil hast du das Gefühl, dass du noch irgendwie akute Wunden im Magen hast? Mein Problem ist, dass ich die Kommunikation mit meinem Körper vor vier, fünf Jahren abgebrochen habe. Wir haben kaum noch Kontakt. Das liegt vor allem an einem Vertrauensverlust, den ich erlitten habe. Den, wer an wen erlitten hat? Wer hat das Vertrauen in? Das interessiert mich wirklich. Ich glaube, mittlerweile ist es gegenseitig. Mein Körper hat das Vertrauen in mich verloren, aber ich kann meinem Körper auch nicht mehr trauen, weil du kennst es ja irgendwie, du isst irgendwas, also du, ja, also du beißt in ein Stück Glas, beißt in eine Murmel, du snackst halt einfach so ein paar Murmeln weg und dann denkst du dir, ist das jetzt gesund oder nicht und dann fühlst du dich plötzlich schlecht, dein Magen tut plötzlich plötzlich weh und du denkst, come on, genau in dem Moment, in dem ich dachte, das ist ungesund, tut jetzt mein Magen weh, ist es dieses psychosomatische Ding oder was oder nicht, genauso wie man immer denkt, oh fuck, keine Ahnung, man atmet irgendwie Rauch ein oder so und dann tut die Lunge weh und dann googelt man Lunge und merkt, die Lunge ist nicht da, wo ich Schmerz habe.
Und dann hört es auch wieder auf, weh zu tun, weil der Körper sagt, ja nee, dann scheiße, dann lass, dann vergiss es.
Also der Körper hat wenig Ahnung auch von sich selbst, wo Dinge sind, weil woher soll, weiss das Gehirn, wo die Lunge ist oder wo die Leber genau ist.
Ich glaube nicht.
Eigentlich nicht, weil die sind ja nur durch so ein Kabel verbunden, aber der pingt ja nicht seinen Ohr durch. Seinen Standort durch. Ne, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das ist aber was Gutes, damit dein Körper, ich glaube, das macht der Körper extra, dass dein Gehirn nicht alles wissen muss, um so ein bisschen, damit halt, wenn irgendwo Schmerzen sind, dein Gehirn nicht automatisch denkt, ah, okay, das ist nur das und das. Das ist ja nur der Blinddarm, den brauche ich ja gar nicht wirklich, ignorieren wir mal, weil dein Gehirn ist ja zu mächtig. Ich glaube, es ist gut, dass du nicht genau weißt, was wehtut. Aber Schmerz gibt es ja nur da, wo irgendwann mal so Schmerzsensoren installiert wurden, oder? Es gibt ja nicht alle Bereiche deines Körpers, können ja Schmerz spielen. Ich glaube, wir sind fast komplett verkabelt mit Schmerzsensoren. Aber es heißt also, dass man im Gehirn nichts fühlt. Also wenn dir jemand in dein Gehirn greifen würde, würdest du es gar nicht merken, weil das keine Sensoren oder Nerven oder sowas hat dafür. Das weiß ich nicht. Das Gute daran ist, dass es ja an Dingen, an Sensoren vorbei muss. Also, weil du hast ja, du fühlst ja auf deiner Kopfhaut und sowas, oder? Ich habe das, ja, auf der Kopfhaut, Haut ist natürlich, bei Haut fühlt man überall was, überall wo Haut ist. Ja klar, aber das ist ja sozusagen die erste Laserlichtschranke, wo Tom Cruise sich vorbeihangeln muss, weißt du, als Schmerz jetzt. Aber du kannst ja, wenn du zum Beispiel was runterschluckst, angenommen, du hast so eine schöne Packung Murmeln und du schluckst die Murmel runter, dann spürst du die im Mund, spürst die im Gaumen, dann schluckst du die runter und dann spürst du sie noch so ein bisschen im Hals, aber dann ist sie weg. Als jemand, der mal eine Murmel verschluckt hat, wirklich, weiß ich das auch noch. Ja, das stimmt. Es tut weh bis, sagen wir mal, so Schlüsselbeinhöhe und dann tut es weh. Nicht mehr weh, dann tut es nicht mehr weh. Dann vergisst dein Körper, dass es gerade grossen Bockmiss gebaut hat. Dann setzt aber so ein unangenehmes Gefühl ein, psychische Natur. Ja, das ist dann aber psychosomatisch, glaube ich, dass das Gehirn sagt, oh, ich glaube, das ist schlecht. Dumme Idee, warum? Lassen wir den Bauch rum, oder vielleicht rumort der Bauch gar nicht, sondern das Gehirn denkt, jetzt müsste eigentlich, eigentlich gibt es ja nur da Schmerz, wo man auch was dagegen machen kann. Du hast ja Schmerz auf der Haut, damit, falls du irgendwo gegen die Gießkanne reifst, dass du auf eine Herdlade greifst, dann kannst du es wegziehen. Du, Flotin hat gerade mit einer aussen den Handgehst eine passende Gießkanne umgeworfen und der Blick, den du dann der Gießkanne zugeworfen hast, hat mir gesagt, dass du seit bestimmt drei Monaten keine Gießkanne mehr gesehen hast. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Es war wie ein Alien, was auf die Erde gelandet ist und sich erstmal ein Auto anguckt. Das war der Blick, die Flotin gerade dieser Gießkanne zu zu nur. Ich weiss auch nicht, warum hier lauter Gießkanne auf Augenhöhe, auf gestikulierhöhe stehen. Das ist ein Risiko, das muss man auch sagen. Stimmt, ist keine Höhe, um dich in Schutz zu nehmen für eine Gießkanne. Gießkanne auf dem Boden. Gehört auf dem Boden oder ganz nach oben. Ja, aber ich meine, du hast ja nur da Schmerz, wo du auch was dagegen machen kannst. Also wenn deine Haut irgendwie gegen Feuer geht, dann kannst du deine zurückziehen. Warum hat man die anderen Teilen Schmerzen in den Zähnen? Ja, damit der Zahn rausgeht. Das ist halt schon die Frage, inwiefern, was erwartet dein Körper von dir? Formulieren wir es so. Welche Erwartungshaltung hat dein Körper an dich, weil wenn du dir sagst, hey Achtung, dein Fingerschmerz, dann kannst du sagen, ah, ich zieh den weg. Oh, Kitzeln heisst ja auch, oh, hier sind Insekten. Meine Mutter hat jetzt massive Schmerzen in der Hüfte. So, Hüftverschleiss. Was soll sie dagegen tun? Nichts kannst du nichts dagegen tun. Was willst du denn gegen Schmerzen? Nee, es tut ja auch dann ultra weh noch. Was sollst du denn dagegen tun? Ja, das ist halt die Frage. Erwartet dann der Körper nicht zu viel von dir? Erwartet dann der Körper jetzt eine Hüft-OP, weil der Körper jetzt schon von dem durchs Gehirn von der Hüft-OP gehört hat. In der Abteilung der Schau hat er gelesen, Hüft-OP, und jetzt hat er das drin. These, Neandertaler hatten noch keine Hüftschmerzen. Starke These. Weil je mehr du über den Körper weisst, desto mehr Schmerzsensoren werden als wichtig empfunden, weil du dir noch was dagegen tun kannst. Hatte Neanderthaler dann Zahnschmerzen? Meine Mutter hatte keine Zahn... achso, Neanderthaler. Ich habe meine Tante verstanden und war ganz verwirrt. Dann hatte ich was verwechselt. Neanderthaler hatten, glaube ich, keine Zahnschmerzen, weil die hatten ja generell... Bei denen war doch alles verfault im Mund, oder nicht? Die konnten doch gar nicht die... Ich weiß nicht, ob man das sagen kann bei den Neandertal-Chromosomen, ob man alles verfault im Mund, ob man das so pauschal sagen kann. Ich weiß es nicht. Mein Gen-Test hat auch gesagt, ich habe mehr Neandertal-Chromosome als ... Deswegen bin ich wahrscheinlich auch eher unintelligent, da kann ich dann auch nichts für, weil ich habe, glaube ich, mehr als 50 Prozent der User bei 23andMe Neanderthal-Chromosomen. Moment, 50 Prozent aller User haben mehr Neanderthaler als Homo sapiens? Nein, ich habe mehr Neanderthaler-Chromosome als 51 Prozent der User von … Ach so. Was aber auch eher … Also auch in … wusste mein Körper auch nicht genau, was es mit dieser Information aufnehmen muss, weil es ja auch in etwa durchschnittlich oder nicht. Ich habe mehr als 51 Prozent. Aber dieses DNA, das ist doch, also ich habe das immer noch nicht gecheckt. Ich glaube, man sagt das immer, weil es heißt dann so, ja, du hast 70 Prozent von der Banane, die DNA. Moment mal, ich habe doch jetzt schon 50 Prozent Nernatale und jetzt nochmal 70 Prozent Banane. Also habe habe ich dann 100, ne das ist 80 % und dann habe ich noch mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Affe, 99 % so viel wie Affe. Also hat der Affe auch 70 % Banane und sind es dieselben Teile, ich habe es da einfach nicht. Und mittlerweile bin ich auch nur noch, es hat sich nämlich geändert, weil jetzt mehr Leute diese Tests gemacht haben. Dadurch werden, verändern sich immer wieder die Daten. Und jetzt bin ich auch nur noch, es hat sich nämlich geändert, weil jetzt mehr Leute diese Tests gemacht haben, dadurch werden, verändern sich immer wieder die Daten. Und jetzt bin ich nur noch drei Orte. Ich bin jetzt nur noch osteuropäisch zu 25%, deutsch zu 75% und dann bin ich 0,7% Sarde. Oh, und wie viele Bananen? Hast du noch einen Bananen drin? Und 0,1% Snickers. Es lassen sich auch immer mehr Bananen testen, dadurch nehmen die so ein bisschen Überhand. Die nehmen ein bisschen Überhand, da hat sich dann kurz die Seite verrannt, aber jetzt werden wieder weniger Bananen getestet. Ja, ich verstehe es nicht, aber ja, kann schon sein, Zahnschmerzen, dann muss der Zahn raus. Wenn du halt so ein Stecker wär, kannst du deinen Zahn selber rausziehen, oder musst du deinen echt echt mit Steigen? Ich glaube, wenn es so richtig schon vom Kern aus Grund verrottet ist, dann geht das, glaube ich. Was für eine dumme Idee mit diesen Zähnen, ey. Ich finde es super. Aber deswegen hat man ja auch vielleicht verschiedene Zähne, weil eigentlich könnte man ja sagen, du hast einfach einen grossen Zahn, so wie einen Fingernagel. Du hast ja auch nur einen Fingernagel. Gut, ja, manche haben mehr als einen Fingernagel. Florentin Will kommt im Podcast und so. Sehr unintelligent. Und du, yes! Aber sonst hättest du, hättest du genauso gut nur einen Zahn haben können. Ja, oder so eine Zahnreihe, wie diese Kauspangen, die man manchmal hat, diese Kauschienen, damit man dich dann nachts mit den Zähnen knirschte. Ja, aber wenn du viele kleine hast, dann kannst du die einzelnen rausziehen und musst dann nicht ihren einen grossen Zahn rausnehmen. Also könnte man schon sagen, Zähne sind das Dach, dass die rausfallen. Haie machen es aber besser. Nein, Haie haben ja drei Zahnreihen. Und wenn ein Zahn vorne rausfällt, weil die sich wieder in einem anderen Fisch verbissen haben, kommt von hinten der Zahn nach vorne. Wird nach vorne weggeschoben und wächst einfach nach. Das Ding ist ja, bei denen wachsen Zähne nach. Und nicht nur das, die haben sogar schon zwei bereits Nachgewachsene in der Hinterhand, die einfach so nachrücken. Move, move, move, move! Und wir haben keinen Zahn mehr. Wenn die Milchzähne erstmal weg waren, auch immer noch komisch, dass das übergeblieben ist. Ist das das Überbleibste davon, dass man mal nachwachsende Zähne hatte eigentlich? Du, ich habe wenig Ahnung, ich bin eher ungetilgert, was das angeht. Milchzähne habe ich eh noch nicht verstanden, warum man gerade da dieses Milchkonzept hat und bei allem anderen nicht, Fingernägel oder so hast du nicht? Milchfinger. Die Milchfinger, die Milchhände und feine Hände gleichzeitig mit den Fingern. Das wäre so geil, wenn man alles einmal zum Testen hat. Weil einmal so ein Prototyp, ja. Ja, so ein Fuck it, jeder macht mal dumme Sachen. So, du hast einen Testmagen für deine Glas-Eskapaden. Ja. Glaskapaden. Es ist ja, also ich glaube, wir machen uns ja immer lustig über Gott und ha ha ha, der hat die Menschen erschaffen, so. Aber ich glaube, wir kommen bald nochmal an den Punkt, wo wir eh irgendwas entschlüsseln oder so, Chromosomen wurde entschlüsselt und wir können halt selber schaffen, was wir wollen. Wir können sagen, ja, du willst Milchhände, kein Problem. Hier, zack, gebe ich hier den Computer ein, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bieb, bie ganz schnell hochgebacken in so einem Backofen oder so, ist dann 25 und sagt, oh der... Natürlich der Dampf. Schleuse geht auf, dampft lichtet sich, also ganz rote Augen. Oh, das ist bestimmt eine gute Idee, diese Kinder mit den roten Augen zu erzeugen und Menschen zu geben. Wer macht ein Foto von ihm? Und dann, glaube ich, müssen wir eh nochmal alles neu, ich glaube, dann kommt eh nochmal alles auf den Prüfstand. Brauchen wir dieses Organ, brauchen wir dieses Organ. Wie wären es mit zwölf Finger? Ach, zwanzig Finger, ein Finger, ein grosser Finger, unterschiedlich grosse Finger pro Hand, so wie die Dalton, so die vier Hauptfinger, unterschiedlich gross. Ja, genau so ist es jetzt gerade. Nein, aber die sind nicht... Jeder hat die Dalton, jeder hat die Dalton, die sind erst mal nicht die Dortons falsch aufgestellt. Hier Abraxas, Rantanplan und Azrael, völlig falsche Aufstellung. Und Gandalf, das ist ganz woanders. Nein, aber ich meine, dass du wirklich so ein Finger ist so eine Salatgurke und einer ist so ein Q-Tip. So, dann kannst du wirklich dann auch die Einsätze gehören. Und einer ist diese Petz-Spender, weißt du, wo oben diese Pets rauskommt. Darauf hat sich die Menschheit geeinigt, ein Finger ist ein Pets-Spender? Ja, klar, warum nicht? Warum nicht? Ich habe C3PO. Zum Sammeln und Tauschen. Ja, ich glaube, da wird nochmal alles neu aufgerollt. Was würdest du am ehesten verändern, wenn du jetzt so ein Genetiker wärst? Was würdest du am ehesten ändern? Ja, mehr Beine. Also ich glaube, Tiere mit mehr Beinen haben Vorteile, vier Beine, schnell unterwegs sein, schnell laufen. Und fliegen wäre natürlich auch schnell schlecht. Ich finde es schön, unter Wasseratmung. Unter Wasseratmung. Wie sieht das denn aus in der Theorie? Ist es ein großer... Du meinst die zweite Lunge? Ach so, die Kiemen. Oder halt so ein großer Mund, der sich so schlauchförmig wie so ein Schnorchel... Ja, das ist der Prototyp, so ein Rüssel, so ein 60 Meter langer Rüssel, damit man auch 60 Meter unter Wasser. Weil, wie gesagt, denk an Klimawandel, Stefan, denk an Klimawandel. Ja. Es wird immer mehr, diese Berge werden schmelzen und es wird immer mehr Wasser und immer weniger Land. Mehr Menschen auf weniger Land. Vorsicht. Okay. Also, Menschen müssen im Wasser leben. Flösschen, Enzymchen. In 3000 Jahren gibt es überhaupt kein Land mehr. Hat die Erde genug Wasser, um alles zu überschwemmen? Nicht alles, glaube ich. Warum nicht? So der K2, da oben der K2, der ist noch trockener, glaube ich. Wieso, warum nicht? Naja, kann doch sein. Wenn da alle, alle Eisberge wegschmelzen, die ganzen Gletscher, denk an die Gletscher. Ich denke an die Gletscher. Wenn die alle abschmelzen, also klar, natürlich sowas wie Mount Everest oder so wird nicht überflutet sein, niemals. Da müsst ihr euch keine Hoffnung machen, aber so die Wohnfläche kann schon alles weg sein, oder? Ich weiss nicht, wo wäre denn der... Das ist doch eh erstaunlich, oder, dass das Wasser genau so viel Wasser auf der Erde ist, dass ungefähr die Hälfte mit Wasser bedeckt ist oder 70 Prozent oder so. Ja, crazy, ne? Das ist so präzise eigentlich. Alles ist präzise, wir sind nur deswegen da. Es könnte genau so sein, dass 99 Prozent der Erde mit Wasser bedeckt ist und wir alle irgendwie auf einer kleinen Inseln stehen. Auf der anderen auf den Schultern. Viel zu heiß. Auf den Schultern von den anderen. Allen Sonnenbrand. Ja, ich hätte genauso gesagt. Aber wie lustig wäre das eigentlich, wenn wir irgendwann so einen Alienplaneten fliegen. Und es ist einfach eine ganz kleine Insel, die wir deswegen wahnsinnig hoch gebaut haben. Ja, genau. So wie dieses Infinite Hotel, diese Matheaufgabe mit diesen unendlichen Stockwerken. Ja, Habohotel. Es ist ein Planet mit diesem riesigen Habohotel, was so wenig Kilometer, Kilometerometer, Kilometer so hunderte von Kilometern nach oben geht und du hast halt so ein paar Etagen und das ist halt deren Welt und das kennen die nur so und warst du schon mal auf Ebene Null? Das wäre eigentlich ein geiles Pen and Paper oder so mal, so ein Planet Die unteren Ebenen sind sauteuer, da kann sich niemand was leisten, weil da halt schon der alte Adel seit tausenden von Jahren lebt und die Armen müssen ganz oben wohnen, wo es halt heisser ist. Das ist richtig heiss. Es gibt ja diese Kurzgeschichte mit dem Turmbau zu Babel, wo die den Turm bauen und irgendwann dann oben an der Decke ankommen. Babel. Babel. Babel. Und die sagen auch, der Turm ist so hoch, dass es Leute gibt, die da geboren wurden und die nie am Boden waren. Richtig. Die immer da unterwegs waren und den höher gebaut haben. Das finde ich super. Und vielleicht gibt es sogar so eine Regel, man kann immer nach oben gehen, aber man kann nie runter, es sei denn, du bist im Stand angemessen. Sowas finde ich cool. Und dann gibt es immer so Radiodurchsagen, so jetzt alle nach rechts lehnen, alle nach rechts lehnen, wenn der Turm so schwankt. Jetzt schnell alle nach rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts, damit wir nicht umfallen und so. Oder es gibt dann vielleicht sogar so eine Terrororganisation, die sich alle dann nach links lehnen, die dann den zum Umstürzen bringen wollen. Linksextrem. Ja, genau. Das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, weil das ist in dem Fall eine Terrororganisation, die schlimmer ist. Ja, da hat man sich, das ist ein bisschen schwierig, aber wie gesagt, das ist ein Alienplanet und wir auch wieder so ein Raumschiff sofort so direkt oben drin. Nope. Langsam. Und dann rückwärts wieder zurück. Hallo, hallo, und dann sieht uns einer von ganz oben, sieht uns so. Genau. Welcome. Der eine. Hey, hallo, heute Zerf, ab geht vielleicht mit Sonnencreme. Wieder weg. Ein Schuss in den Ofer. Ich glaube, ihr Aliens sind die grösste Enttäuschung. Ich glaube, Aliens werden so eine riesen Enttäuschung. Das sind so ganz unangenehme, weirde Typen, mit denen man nichts zu tun haben will. Mein Ziel ist ja, so alt zu werden, dass ich das noch erlebe. Wie arbeitest du daran? Sport, eine gesunde Ernährung, möglichst reich werden, um möglichst mich einfrieren zu lassen, langfristig. Ja, willst du das machen? So wie Walt Disney sich einfrieren lassen? So wie man sagt. Aber ist es nicht die beste Verschwörungstheorie der Welt, weil es gibt ja diese Legende, dass Walt Disney sich hat einfrieren lassen. Das weiss jeder auch. Und deswegen, weil das vertuscht werden sollte, haben die den Film Frozen gemacht. So dass wenn man Walt Disney Frozen googelt, man immer nur den Film findet, aber nicht die Geschichte, dass Walt Disney eingefroren ist. Wie genial ist das denn? Ja, Walt Disney Frozen ist echt ein Problem. Du kannst es quasi nicht googeln.
Es ist ungoogelbar, du kriegst es nicht hin.
Es ist ungoogelbar.
Genau wie dieser Boris Johnson-Bus, das ist eigentlich eine geniale Idee.
Das ist echt...
Das ist fantastisch.
Ja.
Wir müssen sich mal so wirklich alle Filmtitel angucken, wo da Leute eigentlich versuchen...
Ja, was viele auch nicht wissen, das ist nur eine Initiative von Drogenfreiheit und Antidrogenkriminalität, unsere Serie, How to Cell drugs online fast. Ja, richtig. Wenn man das mittlerweile googelt, dann findet man nur haufenweise ... Wollten Sie Drogen verkaufen? Nein, ich wollte die tolle Serie sehen, bislang aber ... Clickbait-Artikel und Torrents, aber du findest nie ernsthaft mehr in der Anleitung. Genial.
Wie vielen Drogenhändlern habt ihr
das Handwerk gelegt?
Sagt man das so?
Ne, rückenfreigehalten meine ich.
Ne, sagt man das Handwerk gelegt?
Sagt man, aber ich meine das genaue Gegenteil eigentlich.
Also du kannst auch was anderes sagen.
Den Rücken freigehalten?
Ja, dadurch, dass sie ihnen Alibi gegeben haben.
Deckung gegeben?
Ja, dass sie ihnen Alibi gegeben haben, dass sie sagt,
den Drogenleuten, die googeln wollten, wie sie Drogen verkauft haben. Nee, die konnten es ja eben nicht mehr googeln, die wollen es ja wissen. Du meinst, die wissen es schon. Die wissen bereits, wo Tortuga liegt. Die, die von der Kriminalpolizei gestellt wurden, warum haben sie gegoogelt, wie man Drogen verkauft? Und ich habe gesagt, ja, ich wollte nur die Serie von Stefan Thiel zu sehen. Jetzt komm, jetzt. Ich dachte eher, dass Leute, die... Ich bitte sie. sehen? Ich wollte die Serie schauen. Ja, wollen wir die Serie schauen? Wollen wir die wirklich, will man die wirklich gucken? Okay, diese cringe Jugendsprache zwei Staffeln lang. Cool, yes, weird. Aber auf der anderen Seite, glaube ich, haben wir eher der Polizei geholfen, weil niemand mehr googeln kann, wie man wirklich Drogen verkauft. Ach ja, stimmt. Es gab immer wirklich einfach sehr gute anschauliche Guidelines, als ich das damals noch gesucht habe, vor der Serie. Und jetzt mittlerweile kann man das nicht mehr finden. Du findest keine Tutorials mehr, du findest nur Artikel über die Serie, die Serie oder so Torrents, wo man die Serie kostenlos gucken kann. Genial, war eine gute Zeit. Das war fantastisch. Gut, zurück zum Notfall. Ja, tolle Geschichte, die ihr euch ausgedacht habt. Aber nicht nur du kannst dir tolle Geschichten ausdenken, sondern auch unsere Zuhörer. Ja! Denn letzte Woche haben wir die Crossover-Geschichten angerissen. Was wäre ein cooles Crossover? Und in der Zwischenzeit ist übrigens der Trailer rausgekommen von Kong vs. Godzilla.
Echt? Ja, wo ich dachte, jetzt! Wir sind am Zahn der Zeit! Wir sind so am Zahn der Zeit! Hollywood hört zu! Das haben wir doch schon lange gesagt, Hollywood hört uns zu. Das habe ich immer schon gesagt, so weiss auch der Podcast, aber wie geil, weil Kong vs. Godzilla ist doch ultra cool! Ist perfekt! Einfach und bestimmt... Aber ich bin für Godzilla. Ich bin auf der der Seite. Ja, ich auch. Ich bin Team Godzilla, definitiv. Warum? Weil Kong weisse Frauen entführt. Ja, weil der Grosses im Laserstrahlen stiessen kann und so. Auch ein bisschen problematisch, ne? Kong, der weisse Frauen entführt, der dunkle, grosse... Ach so, ja. Das finde ich schon irgendwie. Aber am Ende hat er dann nicht auch Gefühle? Ja, aber es ist immer noch so ein bisschen der Indigenous Kong aus dem Urwald, der weisse Frauen entführt. Es ist irgendwie auch ... Ja, muss man mal gucken, wie sich das dann heute umsetzen. Aber wir haben ganz fantastische Kurzgeschichten eingeschickt bekommen von unseren Hörern, die verschiedene Universen, die wir kennen, zusammenbringen. Und ja, viele haben viele Geschichten. Also wir hatten da nur eine Aufgabe, eine Anmerkung dazu, nicht so lang. Genau, und die meisten Geschichten waren sehr lang. Wirklich jetzt? Ja, leider sehr lang, die sind natürlich toll, aber ich habe die Geschichten jetzt nicht nach Qualität ausgesucht, sondern nach Länge.
Ja, ich habe sie nach Länge sortiert auf jeden Fall und das heißt nicht, dass sie nicht gut sind, aber wir haben eine fantastische Geschichte bekommen von Rachel und Rachel wahrscheinlich. Ja, ohne C geschrieben, aber ich weiss nicht, keine Ahnung, Rahel.
Achso, Rahel. Und ich verrate mal nicht, welche Universen es sind, die hier zusammengemischt wurden, das überlasse ich dir. Hier kommt die Mashup-Geschichte von Rachel. Han, der Ring ist wirklich wunderschön, aber ich weiss nicht, meinte Leia unsicher. Es ist nur, bitte halte mich nicht für verrückt, aber ich glaube, das Ding lebt. Entgeistert sah Han auf. Was? Leia, geht es dir gut? Nicht so gut wie sonst. Ich fühle mich seltsam. Was redest du denn da? Han ging auf Leia zu und wollte den Ring von Leias Finger ziehen, doch sie wich zischend zurück. Entschuldige, meinte sie sofort danach und blickte zu ihm auf. Manchmal glaube ich, ihn nachts flüstern zu hören. Han seufzte. Na gut, er war ziemlich billig und der Verkäufer wollte ihn offensichtlich loswerden. Du musst diese Fehlkäufe wirklich in den Griff bekommen, Han, unterbrach Leia ihn. Ich verstehe nicht einmal, was er flüstert. C3PO sagt, die Sprache existiert nicht in seiner Datenbank. Aber C3PO beherrscht quasi alle Sprachen des Universums. Na, vielleicht ist das das Problem, das Universum. Wir sollten Yoda anrufen. Hat jemand seine Nummer? 0800 Dagobah, kann man da irgendwie mal kurz durchklingeln? 555 Grün. Wir sollten Yoda anrufen. Es dauerte eine Weile, bis dieser ihnen helfen konnte. Doch schliesslich hatte er eine Erklärung parat. Das ist Yoda. Und da Sauron es hier nicht gibt, der Ring verwirrt ist, besser loswerden wir ihn sollten, bevor in falsche Hände er kommt. Und jetzt, wenn die das in Musterfall in die Lava schmeißen, wäre mega. Okay, weiter. Er ist durch ein Wurmloch hierher gekommen, fragte Lea fassungslos nach. Und was tun wir jetzt? Woher weiss sie das jetzt? Er ist durch ein Wurmloch aus einer anderen Galaxie hierher gekommen? Das hat niemand gesagt. Wenige Optionen es gibt. Am einfachsten es ist, in ein Wurmloch ihn zurückzuwerfen. Er hielt einen geflochtenen Korb in die Luft, dessen Inneres tiefschwarz waberte. Nach dem Wurf in den Korb, der Lea mehr Willenskraft kostete, als sie gedacht hätte, reiste der Ring lange umher, bis er sich entschloss, einem jungen Mann auf der Erde auf den Kopf zu fallen. Au, empörte sich dieser, was zum ... Er nahm den Ring vom Kopf und betrachte ihn auf.
Stimmt, der Ring bouncet ja nicht so, auch in der Hobbit-Höne.
Der ist so schwer da.
Der fällt auf den Kopf und bleibt dann auf dem Kopf.
Bleibt dann da liegen.
Andere hätten es vielleicht seltsam gefunden, mit Ringen beworfen zu werden. Aber er war Ornithologe und sein Lieblingsvogel war die Elster. Dementsprechend war er wenig überrascht. Trotzdem, mit solch einem Ring konnte er wenig anfangen. Verheiratet war er schon, dezent war der Ring nicht wirklich und Cosplay war auch nicht so seins. Einen plötzlichen Einfall folgend steckte er den überraschend schweren Ring ein, zog er sein Handy aus der Hosentasche und gab Bares für Rares Aufzeichnung Köln in die Suchleiste ein. Einmal Horstlichter treffen, dachte er, das wär's doch. Ein Crossover, was die Welt gebraucht hat. Ein Crossover aus drei Universen, Star Wars, Herr der Ringe und Baris Ferraris. Alle drei sind dabei. Vielen, vielen Dank an Rachel für diese fantastische Kurzgeschichte, die das Beste der Besten zusammenwirft, glaube ich. Die drei wichtigsten Kulturgüter, die wir haben heutzutage, sind da mit drin. Von daher fantastisch. Mal schauen, ob wir in der nächsten Zeit noch weitere vorlesen. Aber wie gesagt, falls ihr noch welche einsenden wollt, gerne kurz. Gerne kurz, wir machen die großen Cross-Aberfolgen. Wir laden auch alle hoch auf der Puffopedia, könnt ihr alle durchlesen. Fantastische Sachen sind da dabei. Ja, die großen Cross-Aber Wochen bei das Podcast-Ufo. Finde ich super, macht mir sehr viel Spaß, aber das stimmt schon, dass man nicht telefoniert hat bei Star Wars. Man hat dann tendenziell eher diese Holo-Kommunikation gehabt, was ich ein bisschen schwierig finde, ehrlich gesagt, weil man will das, so als würde man die ganze Zeit nur FaceTime, aber man will ja nicht. Ich würde Leute anrufen. Außer so in den X-Wings und so. Stefan, kannst du kurz dein Bild anmachen? Wir sehen dich nicht, dein Hodel ist aus. Ach so. Ach so, nee, das ist... Nee, ist auch nur ganz kurz. Wir werden angegriffen. Ja, aber kannst du kurz einfach, dass wir dich auch sehen können, weil das irgendwie so gang und gäbe, dass man sich dann irgendwie zeigt? Ja, ist es so wichtig, müsst ihr sehen, was ich bin. Der Scanner ist auch kaputt. Ich meine, ich trage eine riesige Kapuze über dem Kopf. Ich meine, ist es so wichtig, dass... Wir sind alle gleich angezogen. Wir sind alle, wir tragen alle diese Ordensroben und... Mein Lichtschwert ist grau, grün oder blau, eins von beiden halt. Nicht rot, weil ich bin nicht böse, aber gut. Ne, das ist Quatsch. Ne, und von da, also wirklich, die sehen ja auch alle gleich aus, oder so wenn es heißt Stormtrooper, FaceTime, können wir uns das sparen? Können wir das nicht sparen? Wir brauchen das nicht,
wir können einfach telefonieren.
Haben wir nicht so eingebaute Kommunikatoren?
Toll. Aber ja,
hat Spaß gemacht, ich habe meine Lorien beendet,
dieses Wochenende habe ich mir
reingebinged, schön in meine Augen
reingenommen und
deine Augen, deine zwei kleinen
Gesichtslöcher reingeschnissen
und hat es dir gefallen?
Sieben Löcher hat der Kopf und in zwei davon habe ich mir die Lichtstrahlen reingegeben, also habe auf den Monitor gestarrt.
Und hat es dich begeistern können.
Runde Augen, aber viereckiger Monitor, da war ich eher skeptisch, dachte mir, wie geht das?
Aber es ging, es hat funktioniert und die Internetverbindung ist top gehalten. Ja, so hat es denn gefallen. Und ja, erst war ich ein bisschen verwirrt, weil erst wollte ich die Serie gucken und habe dann aber auf die Doku geklickt auf Disney Plus und habe das dann erst gedacht, das ist merkwürdig, das ist so eine Art Mockumentary irgendwie. Ich dachte eigentlich, das ist eher so eine normale Serie, aber dann habe ich relativ schnell gemerkt, oh, das ist die Doku. Wollte mich nicht spoilern lassen. Die Office trifft Mandalorian auch in einem Crossover, wenn Mandalorian dann so in einer abgesetzten O-Ton sitzt und sagt, Jim, geht mir so auf die Nerven mit seinen Pranks die ganze Zeit. Aber dann habe ich relativ schnell gemerkt, nee, das ist nicht die richtige Serie, bin nochmal rausgegangen und habe dann noch mal Frozen geguckt, dann nochmal Frozen 2 und dann war ich dann noch mal Frozen 1, weil es viele Fragen gab. Genau, ob ich die Anspielungen richtig verstanden habe. Und dann war es schon echt spät. Und dann habe ich mich ins Bett gelegt.
Und linke Hälfte, rechte Hälfte der Bettseite.
Mit Maske auf und Scherben in der Lunge. Tschüss Welt, Flo ist raus. Das war's. Macht's gut, Leute, ich bin raus, ciao. Das heißt, man kann dich jetzt durchaus bald sehen, vielleicht Tod in deinem Bett liegt, Maske auf, Todes Sache sind Scherben im Magen und nebenan, ach du noch im Bett, liegt da noch, guckst du in Mandalorian, Behind the Scenes und man sieht, dass du noch nicht mit der Serie durch bist, aber schon mit Behind the Scenes. Das ist durchaus ein vorstellbares Bild, wo man dich finden könnte. Du, ich mache mir echt immer Sorgen, wenn ich jetzt sterbe, wie finden Leute meine Leiche? Das ist ein großes Problem von mir. Ja, arbeite mal stärker dran vielleicht. Ja, ja, ich weiß schon, ja. Aber das ist echt das Leben. Ich muss das auch echt erst mal liegen bleiben. Ich dachte mir so, meine Herren, bist du dumm und lag da erst mal mit meiner Maske im Bett und dachte mir, wie kann das sein? Wirst du dümmer auch? Wirst du dümmer? Ich glaube, wir werden wirklich dümmer. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Man baut ab, glaube ich, nach, im Alter von 20 oder so baut man ab. Aber ich habe nicht auch letztens so eine Schlagzeile gelesen, irgendwie, diese Generation ist die erste, seit es den Menschen gibt, die nicht intelligenter ist als die letzte Generation. Doch, das glaube ich nicht. Das ist Unfug. Na gut, das kannst du jetzt mit der Schlagzeile ausdiskutieren. kannst du dir gerne anschreien. Ich gehöre zu der schlechten Generation, der dummen, eher unintelligenten Generation. Wir sind ja alle eher unintelligent. Ich kann das jetzt gar nicht bewerten, ich kann diese Buchstaben aneinanderreihen, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, was es bedeutet. Ja, aber hat man da nicht so wieder so ein Ding mit Dunning-Kruger, dass wenn du sagst, du bist schlau, bist du eigentlich dumm, aber wenn die Forscher jetzt rausfinden, dass wir eigentlich dümmer sind, ist es dann nicht eher wieder, dass wir schlauer sind, weil wir zu dieser Dunning-Kruger-Effekt anders kommen. Das ist genau das gleiche, wie wenn man im Channel Unpopular Opinions als eher unterliegt. Das ist genau ähnlich unlösbar, die Aufgabe. Ich glaube auch, das ist der Zenit, wir bauen wieder ab. Das braucht man auch nicht, wir haben noch alles. Außer Milchfinger haben wir eigentlich alles, was wir brauchen. Wir haben eigentlich alles aus dem Milchfinger, Wasser kommt aus dem Wasserhahn. Oh, ich habe letztens nochmal gegoogelt, die beste Nachricht, die ich diese Woche bekommen habe. Ich habe ja meinen Vormieter, meinen Vormieter, hat mir gesagt, ein heißes Bad zu nehmen, kostet 15 Euro.
Und seitdem verbreite ich diese Kunde überall und sage, Leute, wisst ihr, dass das echt relativ kostspielig ist und habe das aber nicht hinterfragt.
Und habe jedes Mal, weil ich nehme ganz gerne Bad und habe jedes Mal, wenn ich ein Bad genommen habe, mir dachte, jetzt hast du aber diese Woche schon 15 und zweimal in der Woche im Monat und so, da kommt schon was zusammen, nimm mal heute kein Bad. Das war wenig in Gedanken, wie du hattest. Hast du dann immer auch 15 Euro von deinem normalen Girokonto auf so ein Zahlgeldkonto rübergelegt? Auf so ein Badkonto abgewiesen, ja. Und dann habe ich aber jetzt irgendwann mal recherchiert, ob das stimmt, stellt sich heraus, stimmt überhaupt nicht. Also überhaupt nicht. Ein Bad kostet mehr so 1,50, so 1,30, so Faktor 10 falsch. Und ich dachte mir, verdammt nochmal, ich habe mir so viele Bäder durch die Finger fliessen lassen. Im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Weil ich Geld sparen wollte. Und jetzt nehme ich fast jeden Tag ein Bad, weil warum nicht? Also was ist, ich meine, was machen wir denn den ganzen Tag? Wir schauen einen Bildschirm an und warum das nicht einfach im heissen Wasser machen? Du kannst ja alles, was du so machst, auch im heissen Wasser machen. Oh, und ich habe gehört, der Körper fühlt sich umarmt, weil so viele Nervenenden berührt werden vom Wasser. Es ist ein gutes Gefühl für den Körper, auch gerade wenn ihr gerade alleine seid in der Lockdown-Zeit,, alles für uns alle eine schwierige Zeit, dann nehmt doch mal ein Bad, dann fühlt ihr euch berührt. Nicht wirklich, aber ihr könnt den Körper austricksen, dass es euch besser geht, als es euch eigentlich geht. Ja, weil alles ist besser in der Badewanne, also wirklich, egal was du machst. Außer Dinge, wofür du trockene Finger brauchst. Gut, ach so, du spielst jetzt irgendwie Rummikub oder so oder Mikado. Ja, wohl, nasse Hände könnten auch gut sein. Aber so, ich habe ja so ein kleines Bügelbrett, das ich dann über die Badewanne lege, Laptop drauf und dann einfach schön nach der Serien binchen. Du hast schon so eine unsympathische Routine wahrscheinlich, dem so offenbart, das ist auch meine These, je besser Menschen in etwas werden, desto mehr denken sie, sie wären nicht so gut darin, aber dann finde ich jetzt aber, wer sowas, je unsympathischer werden sie für den äußeren Betrachter aber auch, je häufiger du ein Bart nimmst, hast du schon so ein Bügelbrett drauf und hast dir schon so Kerzen hingelegt und dann so legst du da schon eine Schale mit Nüsschen dahin, aber nicht zu viel, weil du willst nicht so weit frisst du dich, dann hast du noch so ein kleines Glas da stehen und danach so eine Limon Flaschimulade mit Zitrone drin. Und so eine ganz unsympathische, viel zu lang vorbereitete, einstündige Routine. Und dann gehst du ins Bad und hast alles perfekt vorbereitet. Unsympathisch ein bisschen. Ich habe viele Snacks durchprobiert während der Badewanne, bin jetzt auf Gewürzgürkchen gekommen, das ist ideal. Auch weil du die Innerwanne aus der Wanne essen kannst. Ja, aber ich hatte auch direkt eine Idee, Achtung Guido, aufgepasst, eine direkte Idee für eine neue Talkshow. Und zwar, du hast ein Studio mit zwei Badewannen, die stehen nebeneinander, darin sind die Gäste. Du hast dann einmal Guido Kanz und dann Jeanette Biedermann auf der anderen Seite. Und dazwischen den Badewannen steht aber ein Tisch, wo ganz viele verschiedene Gewürzgurken platziert sind. Also so die verschiedenen Aufsgläsern-Spraywaldgurken, verschiedene Gurken. Und dann hast du einerseits einen Talk zwischen Guido Kanz und Jonathan Biedermann, was natürlich interessant ist, weil man liegt in der Badewanne, man ist entspannt, das ist eine ungewöhnliche Situation für ein Interview. Es ist irgendwie die Privatsphäre. Alles eine sehr ungewöhnliche Situation. Auch die Gewürzgurken sind irgendwie eher ungewöhnlich, würde ich sagen. Man öffnet sich mehr, glaube ich, wenn man, ich glaube, zu zweit in der Badewanne zusammen sein, das ist dann schon wieder so ein bisschen zu nah. Aber wenn jeder seine eigene Badewanne hat, glaube ich, dann öffnet man sich. Und dann immer, wenn einem kein Gesprächsthema einfällt, kann man sagen, und wie schmeckt dir die Gewürzgurke, findest du die besser als die andere oder nicht? Soll ich jetzt was dazu sagen zu dieser Idee? Muss ich die jetzt bewerten?
Muss ich die jetzt wirklich von einer Skala von 1 bis 10 bewerten?
Wie viele Gewürzgurken würdest du dieser Idee geben?
Ich würde zwei Gewürzgurken.
Zwei von fünf?
Nee, von 20.
Ich finde es okay.
Glaubst du nicht, dass Fernseh Deutschland
innovative neue Talkshows braucht?
Erstmal glaube ich nicht, dass es bei Gewürzgurken, verstehe mich nicht falsch, ich mag Gewürzgurken, aber so wahnsinnig viele Unterschiede gibt. Ja, aber die Unterschiede werden ja grösser, wenn du die direkt nebeneinander stellst. Wenn du direkt eine isst, dann die andere. Ja, aber selbst dann findest du halt leicht bessere Gewürzgurken. Im besten Fall schafft es die Sendung, leicht bessere Gewürzgurken zu finden und Johnnet Biedermann ein bisschen mehr brenzlige Details aus dem Privatleben heraus zu kitzeln, weil sie sich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr öffnet, weil sie in eine heiße Badewanne sitzt. Ja, genau. Ich finde es ideal. Ich habe schon viele Probeinterviews alleine bei mir im Badezimmer geführt, viele Probetalks gemacht mit verschiedenen Leuten und die waren immer super. Das glaube ich dir, das glaube ich dir wirklich vom Herzen. Der beste Pitch. Ich habe das mal in meinem Kopf durchgespielt und das hat mir richtig viel Spaß gemacht. Also ich glaube, das ist eine gute Idee. Ich weiß nicht, Baden ist bei mir immer so eine Sache. Ich finde das ganz schön und ich freue mich dann auch immer, wenn das Bad einläuft und so. Und dann stehe ich mir ein wenig eine Kerze dahin und nehme ein cooles Getränk und sowas. Und dann habe ich auch mittlerweile einen breiten Rand, da kann ich meinen Laptop draufstellen, das ist toll. Und so, dann gehe ich dann rein, aber dann vergesse ich immer das Handtuch mir hinzulegen, damit ich meine Hände abtrocknen kann, damit ich den Laptop wieder benutzen kann. Und jetzt dann immer drin oder versuche mich hier reinzulegen, ohne die Hände ins Wasser zu nehmen. und dann bin ich so einot. Setz euch mal in die Badewanne, ohne euch abzustützen, weil die Hände nicht nass werden dürfen. Ihr seht aus wie Deppen, wie man die Hände weit nach oben streckt und sich ganz langsam hinsetzt, ohne den Schwerpunkt ganz weit nach hinten zu verlegen, wenn man nicht umkippt. Lächerlich. Nee, kleiner Tipp an der Stelle, ich kann mir ein paar Tipps geben, und zwar, ich habe immer, wenn ich bade, bestimmt fünf Küchenhandtücher dabei. Ich sag ja, das ist so unbefallend. Vergiss Badezimmerhandtücher, die sind zu dick, du brauchst die dünnen Küchenhandtücher. Aber es findet auch total an Romantik gerade, dein Bad, wenn du halt fünf Spreewald-Gurken-Gläser da stehen hast, acht Küchentücher, Laptop, dann ein kleines Handtuch, dann eine zerberstete Tomateflasche für alle Fälle, man weiß es nicht, Feuerlöscher, weil du hast auch schon mal Probleme mit den Kerzen gehabt. So, ja, aber nee, und der Raum ist super romantisch. Wenn ich dich einladen würde auf Badewanne-Date, schön mal mit ein paar Gürkchen. Hat fest und frau dich mal gemacht, sonst könnten wir das mal machen, eine Folge aus der Badewanne. Ja, stimmt, das ist eigentlich keine keine schlechte Idee. Aber haben die schon gemacht, deswegen machen wir es nicht. Weil wenn du fünf Küchenhandtücher hast, kannst du die sehr flexibel einsetzen. Du kannst zwei davon als Kopfstütze nehmen, du kannst eine davon nehmen, die auf den Kopf zu legen, du kannst eine aufs Bügelbrett legen, damit du immer deine Hände oder deine Finger so ein bisschen abtrocknen kannst. Du hast viel Flexibilität, dadurch, dass du fünf T Tücher hast, kannst du die immer umschichten. Drei hinter dem Kopf, zwei zum Abtrocknen, zwei macht sie nass, mach eins komplett nass, du hast genug. Du hast genug. Mach eins nass und legst so unterm Wasser hinter deinen Nacken. Du hast die, alle Möglichkeiten sind offen. Wenn du nur ein Handtuch hast, würdest du es nicht nass machen. Wohingegen, wenn du fünf hast, kannst du eins auf eins verzichten. Ja, finde ich gut. Ich möchte mal so einen Kurs geben. Es gab, es gibt doch bei, habe ich letztens gelernt. Masterclass finde ich gut, Baden, wenn man schlurken will. Ja, das ist auch nicht schlecht und immer so ganz, ganz flapsig zensiert. Das ist Baden, das ist mein Masterclass. Der Balken rutscht immer wieder so ein bisschen weg. Ich bin zu schnell für den Balken. Es ging zu viel Geld drauf für die ganzen Bäder, zu viel 15 Euro für die ganzen Bäder, aber kein Geld mehr fürs gute Zensieren. Der Zensurbalken ist immer so 10 Frames hinterher. Teuerste Masterclass, schon einmal durchgerechnet. Also für die Masterclass brauche ich ungefähr 90 Bäder, 90 mal 15 sind Pima Daumen 80.000 Dollar. Ja, aber ich habe letztens gehört, Airbnb habe ich immer gehalten für Leb in der Wohnung von fremden Menschen. Es stimmt aber nicht, es gibt auch, man kann da so Art Führungen oder Workshops anbieten in Städten. Das heißt, wenn du in der Stadt bist, da kannst du auch so, ich mache jetzt hier so Streetart Führung und dann so die Stadt geführt und dann kannst du Streetart angucken oder so. Baden mit Florentin. Oder baden mit Florentin. Gut, es ist nicht die beste Zeit, um solche Tipps rauszuhauen, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, aber ich finde es generell nicht schwierig. Würde ich anbieten, ich in so einem Badehaus und dann mal so richtig baden. Ich weiß nicht, ob da Leute kommen würden. Ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen creepy. Gut, dann komme ich, also wie muss ich mir das vorstellen? Ich komme dann zu dir nach Hause. Genau. Du vermiedest... Ich bin schon entkleidet. Komplett oder hast du noch ein Handtuch? Komplett. Klar, weil du direkt auch die Angst nehmen willst. Ich will die Angst nehmen und... So, dann komme ich in dein Bad. Das ist wahrscheinlich so ein normales, durchschnittsdeutsches Bad. Genau, und dann würde ich sagen, Herr Tizze, schön, dass Sie da sind. Zunehmen Sie doch einfach mal. Siezen aber, du bist komplett nackt, aber die Distanz wüsste dir wahr. Natürlich. Jetzt nehmen Sie doch einfach mal ein Bad, wie Sie ganz normal bei sich ein Bad nehmen würden. Machen Sie einfach mal ganz normal. Also erst mal, es ist schwierig jetzt in die Situation, mich da rein zu versetzen, weil was sind schon für Fehler passiert, bis zu der Entscheidung, bei dir zu stehen, um jetzt ein Bad zu nehmen. In welchem Geisteszustand bin ich? Ja, das heißt, mein Geisteszustand wäre eher nicht okay, ich ziehe mich aus, weird, da ist ein nackter Mann vor mir, nein, mein Geisteszustand wäre ja, ja, bislang passiert alles so wie erwartet, oder nicht? Und ich freue mich auch darüber, weil genau das wollte ich ja auch. Währenddessen beobachte ich dich aus einer respektvollen Distanz, drei Meter. Kamera? Ist die Kamera ein paar? Ja, Kamera ist natürlich... Für Notfälle, damit du einschreiten kannst. Für Notfälle und damit wir noch mal die Nachbetrachtung machen, was du alles falsch gemacht hast. Also wird auch aufgezeichnet. Wird alles aufgezeichnet. Okay, gut. Beruhigend. Also ich platziere mich hinter der Kamera und schaue durch das Objektiv. Also in diesem Zeitpunkt muss ich mir deine Wohnung aber vorstellen. Primär ein riesen Observation Room, also dein Wohnzimmer, wo du so eine ganz viele Monitorkameras von allen Perspektiven und dein kleines Bad ist zugestellt mit Handtüchern, Gurken. Genau, da steht ein ganzes Regal von verschiedenen Utensilien, die du dir nehmen kannst, aber nicht musst. Ich sage, nehmen sie, was sie brauchen, wo sie sich gut fühlen und fühlen sie sich wohl. Gut, ich würde mich dann entkleiden, ebenso. Machen Sie nur, wie Sie wollen. Das finden Sie jetzt merkwürdig. Machen Sie, wie Sie möchten. Also ist das Bad schon eingelaufen? Nein, nein, nein. Von dir ist nichts vorbereitet. Ich will ja sehen, wie du es machst. Das ist die, hä? Du vermietest dein Bad, damit du sehen kannst, wie andere baden? Also, Sie sind hergekommen, um baden zu lernen,
nicht um meine pädagogischen Maßnahmen zu hinterfragen.
Also möchte ich Sie bitten, nehmen Sie bitte jetzt ein entspanntes Bad.
So, dann will ich erstmal in dein Bad gehen.
Okay, ja.
So, und dann würde ich, dann mache ich die Badewanne an.
Und erstmal so schön heiß.
Aber auch so heiß,
dass so viel Wasser rauskommt,
dann würde ich mir zum Schrank gehen und so ein Schaumbad rausnehmen. Okay. Warte mal, ihr wirst nicht so mal so falsch machen. Machen Sie erst mal, wie Sie meinen. Okay, und danach würden Sie mir sagen, was Sie jetzt schon falsch finden, weil ich sehe in Ihrem Gesicht, dass Sie das gerade... Wie gesagt, machen Sie erst mal ganz entspannt. Ich lasse nur Wasser ein und mache... Ja, nee, wie Sie denken. Machen Sie einfach mal so, wie Sie denken, Sie sind ja hier, um zu lernen.
Ja, dachte ich, bis gerade auch. Ich würde, also ein bisschen Wasser läuft gerade schon, dann nehme ich ein Schaumbad aus dem Schrank, mache die richtige Anzahl an Kappen voll, die da hinten auf der Verpackung stehen. Ganz okay, sich vielleicht ein bisschen zurückhalten. So, dann wundere ich mich natürlich über die sehr vielen Gewürzgurken, die im Regal stehen, ignoriere die aber erstmal mit so einem Blick, mit so einem verwirrten Blick. Dann würde ich das reinmachen in die Badewanne. So, wenn es voll genug ist, weil ich rechne natürlich auch noch meinen Körper mit ein, der gleich in die Wanne plumpst und natürlich den Schmere-Spiegel anhebt. So, das habe ich natürlich im Blut. Ich Macht die Wanne aus, die ist jetzt schon schaumig. Nie schaumig genug, ganz kurz, auf Character, weil das funktioniert nie so richtig, diese Schaumbäder. Aber bei mir liegt es auch ein bisschen am Wasserdruck, weil bei mir tröpfelt das so nach und nach, ein Tropfen nach und nach raus. Eigentlich habe ich... Das mir? Ja. Ihr braucht keinen Schaum.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, in diesem Kameraraum, in diesem Raum, wo sehr viele Kameras am Gerät sind, habe ich zuerst Bedürfnissen, dass ich nicht viel Schaum. Was bringt dir wirklich der Schaum?
Flauschiggefühl.
Wie, Flauschiggefühl, dein Körper ist unter Wasser.
Und was ich immer noch mache und was ich hoffe, was ich nie verlieren werde und auch noch mit 55 machen werde, ist ab und zu so eine Schaufel, Hand machen, ein bisschen Schaum und dann pusten. Klar. Okay, dafür sage ich ja. Okay, das ist okay. Aber ansonsten wird der Schaum... Und je feiner der gepustet, je trockener der ist, desto feiner kann man ihn pusten. Dann kommt ganz viel... Ja, ein bisschen macht es auch. Hast du den auch schon mal gegessen? Ja. Weil da denke ich mir immer so, Badewannenwasser ist ja Lauge, das ist ja so Spülmittel. Kannst du essen. Und das ist ja nichts anderes als eine Brezel. Ich weiß nicht, ob es dein Scherbenproblem, also ob es gut für deine offenen Wunden in deinem Magen ist, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob du in den nächsten drei Tagen Schaum essen solltest. Ja, vielleicht sollte ich da wirklich mich mal zurückhalten. Halt dich mal kurz zurück. Vielleicht hilft es aber auch deinem Problem. Aber ich denke mir so, wenn du das Wasser nur heiß genug machst, dann wirst du zu einer schönen Laugenstange eigentlich, oder? Weil das ist ja Lauge, das ist ja das. Du wirst dann einfach, kriegst dann so eine schöne und dann ist Salz noch oben drauf. Hm, lecker. Wann mal ein bisschen. So, dann, ja, dann wundere ich mich dann nochmal über das Bügelbrett, was da steht. Ich habe meinen Laptop mitgebracht, schön Mandalorian drauf, Disney Plus. Die Doku, oder? Die Doku, natürlich. Die gucke ich immer zwischendurch. Ich gucke mal eine Folge der Serie, eine Folge. Ich habe leider nicht einhaken an der Stelle, ich lasse sie einfach mal weitermachen. So, und dann würde ich das Bügelbrett auf die Wanne legen und schön Mandalorian anmachen. Licht hätte ich ausgemacht schon, Kerzchen an. Ausgemacht. Licht ist komplett aus, zappenduster. Sehr gut, also ich sage erstmal nichts, aber. Rufst du aus dem Nebenraum oder aus dem Mikro, aus der Gegensprecherlage. Sehr gut, es dröhnt viel zu laut im Bad, sehr gut. Rotes Licht an, wenn ich spreche. Ja, dann würde ich es mir da schön gemütlich machen. Vielleicht schreibe ich auch schon die Bewertung für diesen Airbnb-Aufenthalt parallel, weiß ich noch nicht. Ja, wie viele Sterne würden Sie geben? Zwei. Von zwanzig? Von fünf. Achso, dann nehme ich. Gut, und dann. Beste Bewertung bis jetzt. Mich rausgehen, mich abtrocknen, aufpassen, dass nicht so viel Wasser auf den Fussboden kommt, schön abrubbeln, mich wieder anziehen, dann das sehr befriedene Geräusch machen, wenn man den Pömpel hochmacht. Und dann würde ich mich bedanken, recht herzlich, und mit dir die Nachbesprechung geben. Ja, Herr Tietze, da war doch schon viel Gutes dabei. Können Sie, Sie haben hier bei Minute 16 haben Sie einmal relativ lange auf die Gewürzgurkengläser gestarrt, sich dann aber dagegen entschieden, sie in ihr Badeerlebnis zu integrieren. Können Sie da vielleicht nochmal darauf eingehen, was hat Sie dazu bewogen? Ich wusste jetzt nicht, was ich damit soll, weil erst mal habe ich die schiere Menge, ich habe noch nie diese Menge an Gewürzgurkengläser gesehen, das hat mich schon ein bisschen verwirrt. Dann wusste ich aber auch nicht, wie viele verschiedene es gibt, habe mich dann sehr beeindruckt, ehrlich gesagt. Dann habe ich mich an diese Sendung erinnert, die es einmal gab, die wir kennen, und Janet Biedermann, die komplett verr Ja, aber vielleicht auch falsch verstanden. Da habe ich mich erinnert, da sehen Sie mich auch lachen, Sie sehen mich, mein Körper wackelt für fünf Minuten. Ja, das habe ich gesehen. Das haben Sie gesehen, da habe ich gelacht, da habe ich es einfiel. Und da habe ich beschlossen, dass ich nicht in mein Bade-Erlebnis zu integrieren. Aha, gut. Ja, Fehler. Das war falsch. Ja, okay. Das muss ich jetzt an der Stelle dann doch so deutlich sagen. Das war wirklich ein Riesenfehler und Sie sind damit auch leider bei mir durchgefallen. What? Deswegen kann ich Ihnen leider das Badezertifikat nicht aushändigen. Ich möchte Sie bitten, dass Sie an der Stelle auch meine Wohnung verlassen. Und ich werde mir, ja, ich werde selbst entscheiden, wie mit den weiteren... Sie schmeissen mich raus, Sie haben immer noch nichts an. Ich möchte, dass Sie jetzt meine Wohnung verlassen. Sie haben immer noch nichts an. Ich möchte Sie bitten, jetzt meine Wohnung zu verlassen an der Stelle, ansonsten muss ich zu rechtlichen Konsequenzen greifen, und das möchte ich nicht. Da ziehen Sie den Strick, da ziehen Sie die Linie. Herr Tietze, bitte, ich möchte jetzt das Gespräch beenden und Sie der Wohnung verweisen. Ich dachte hier, Sie bringen mir Baden bei.
Herr Tietze, Sie haben die Entscheidung getroffen.
Können Sie sich was anziehen?
Sie müssen mit der Konsequenz leben.
Herr Tietze, bitte!
Können Sie sich was anziehen?
Ich möchte nicht von Ihnen aus der Wohnung geschmissen werden, wenn Sie nichts anhaben.
Herr Tietze, bitte, es tut mir leid, so funktioniert das nun mal.
Und auch Sie werde ich bei der Bewertung von Ihnen selber hart ins Gericht nehmen müssen. Wissen Sie was? Ich gehe jetzt. Vier von fünf Sternen. Danke. Also das geht auch auf Airbnb. Also wie gesagt, da könnt ihr auch gucken, dass ihr da vielleicht mal so die Stadt kennenlernt, irgendwie mit ein paar interessanten Gestalten aus der Umgebung. Aber nicht jetzt, nicht jetzt.
Nee, nicht jetzt auf keinen Fall. Jetzt müsst ihr andere
Dinge tun, und zwar ganz wichtige Dinge,
die ihr schon lange vor euch hergeschoben
habt, die könnt ihr jetzt angehen.
Lebt euer Leben, geniesst eure
Macht die Steuer, räumt mal auf, oh Gott,
die Leute mit so einem furchtbaren Gefühl entlassen.
Denkt an eure Aufgaben, die ihr bislang vernachlässigt habt,
um diese Folge zu hören. Das geht auch noch morgen,
schiebt euch hin. Ohne Scheiss, gerade ist doch eh alles on hold.ssigt habt, um diese Folge zu hören. Das geht auch noch morgen, schiebt euch hin.
Ohne Scheiss, gerade ist doch eh alles on hold.
Ja, niemand wird es euch böse nehmen.
Guckt mal was an, schaut mal noch einen alten Film, den ihr schon tausendmal gesehen habt und habt eine schöne Woche.
Bis dahin, haut rein.
Habt eine fantastische Woche, ciao, ciao.
Ciao, mach's gut, ciao.
It's the worst Burr-Production.